so you would
doing elementary school sorry no no
tangents are over very well
as long as one of us remembers where we
were yeah it's okay gotta bring it back
i actually stopped drawing in college
you know i'm not gonna use this for work
so right i'm not gonna yeah and uh but
obviously the whole time secretly i
really that was where my passion you
missed it you missed it yeah and the
moment i realized uh was actually during
like a big lecture hall in my second
semester of my senior year there was a
professor who was giving a very
passionate speech
um
and i remember she was like
i have to commend every single one of
you that's sitting here today because
you're about to enter a thankless field
where you get screwed over by the
government you get screwed over by
administration you'll get screwed over
by parents and you don't get paid [ __ ]
for it but you're doing it because this
is your calling and what you truly want
to do
get me out of here
i was sitting there like wait no this
this wasn't this isn't my bad that's not
what i signed up for
[Music]
most people in lecture was trying to
sell you on the topic they're not just
like okay you're going to hate your life
you're going to regret everything like
damn you must really like kids
because i did like engineering because i
was like at least you make mad bank yeah
yeah i mean i don't like you but i would
have got paid a lot and i was like okay
why why
elementary school teaching i honestly as
you're like i got nothing else to do
because my parents were like oh well i
mean if you if you don't if you can't do
art uh just be a teacher
[Music]
why is that like the next like
progression oh you don't wanna do
anything just teach [ __ ] kids they
were like you can draw for fun on the
side and i was like okay because i was
like 16 and i didn't yeah yeah
yeah um
yeah and so after i graduated uh one of
my friends gifted me a drawing tablet um
as a graduation present yeah like you
should draw again right and i was like
okay maybe yeah i will after i graduate
and then um i visited my parents in
korea and they lived kind of in the
middle of nowhere so i had nothing to do
yeah so during that like month i was
there i just drew the entire time and i
was having so much fun right like i
wouldn't even leave like the guest room
that i was in my parents are like hello
are you okay go outside you're in a
foreign country
and uh
i ended up posting
like uh some videos it was honest it was
just like drawings to like songs right
and i put it on youtube you're like the
amv wasn't good enough so you're like
i'll make it
myself
it's not good enough wasn't you drawing
to music or was it you like your
drawings edited to drawings edited to me
what was the song um anyways what was
the song what was the song so what was
the song after uh
emily what's the song dude and by the
time
what is the song
what song is it
no i'm embarrassed well i mean we're
gonna find out eventually
what is it emily um you know do you know
uh the song it's not like i like you by
static feet
it was cute i thought it was cute i won
that song that blew up and was
everywhere on youtube yeah recommended
yes yes i know the one yeah that one
didn't we sing that last time we went to
karaoke or was that died it's like i
remember no that's not ontario
okay okay yeah okay but like 2015 that
was
on youtube recommended plastered if you
watched any anime videos i think like
was it 2018. i think like 60 percent of
youtubers use that as their outro yeah
yeah like it was everywhere it was it's
a cute song
and i and i i drew to it and it did
really well surprisingly and uh i think
i posted like a work in progress version
because i was like maybe i'll finish it
and then like a wave of people were like
finish it and i was like okay and so i
finished it and it did super well and
then i was like oh wow this is a lot of
fun by super well what kind of what kind
of reviews are we talking about like how
many people were coming to this one
video that you put out do you remember
at the time yeah when i got really
excite like 100k
that's a law firm
for a while i was in korea i was like
whoa 100k that's nuts 100k for first
uploads like ridiculous that is
ridiculous is that like your first time
using editing software as well like this
is
yeah and okay you know what's funny so i
i'm still really bad at using editing
software but i didn't even know what the
[ __ ] the dimensions for a youtube video
was
you're like guessing that's the black
part
it's like 4x3
so like i've thought about like
recreating it
with like improved art
but also like people go to that video
thinking it's like a video from like
2012 and they're like 2018.
yeah so
uh by the time i
flew back home i think i had like 10 000
subs jeez
from one video from one video
while i was in korea i uploaded like a
bunch okay what did you do what was your
please what kind of stuff did you like
it was it was still like songs are just
music all right
basically like unmonetizable stuff yeah
so just like youtube no i could monetize
yeah youtube's just like copyright
claiming that [ __ ] like so
would you watch a lot of youtube before
this or is it kind of like you can
casually watch casually all right okay
okay um
[Music]
yeah but i had a lot of fun i mean a lot
of my older videos i've unlisted now
just because like it embarrasses me to
see the art wait did you unleash the
league of legends impression one
so anyways
so one of my friends
[Laughter]
emily emily did this league of legends
impression video it's so good one of my
friends
it's so funny now you're gonna explain
one of my friends uh then informed me
that i could monetize stuff on my
channel you're like what
yeah did you make money yeah they were
like have you ever considered like
monetizing your stuff and i was like you
can do what now like i've just been
doing this for fun well that's weird
cause youtube normally like did you know
you can make money yeah immediately yeah
they're really really really really good
in your face especially if you get like
100k views that's like just like oh do
you want do you want to make money turn
on the dollar sign
turn it on
at that point i didn't even consider the
idea that i could do youtube full-time i
was like well this was fun i missed like
drawing i don't think anyone does right
they're just like oh i can make like 10
bucks here on there that's pretty sick
yeah yeah it's like pocket change yeah
the first time you see that graph go to
like five bucks you're like
i remember the first youtube paycheck i
got it was like 200 or something and i
remember like
running home from work and i was like i
got grocery money i'm so excited
um and yeah that's kind of how it
happened but i didn't tell my parents
uh for a while because i knew that if i
told them too early
they would try to discourage me right
yeah you're gonna get that bang first
yeah yeah yeah
where i'm
like i'm doing youtube yeah oh but will
it make you money yes
you got to slap them with the fat stacks
before they even question you right yeah
here's a grant
yeah here you go and they were like oh
okay
[Music]
i i was like with my parents when i
first started making money because we
were on vacation yeah back when i was
18 19 still and they were like you made
four dollars
really that's insane how did you do that
like from the video like what how does
that work that's so like encouraging
yeah because i was definitely on emily's
side i didn't tell my parents i was
doing youtube until like at least a year
and a half yeah my parents are just like
that's that's [ __ ] about it yeah for
me i was like parents i'll keep going
parent trade offer
i quit my job and i give myself a year
and you get my love and support if i
succeed
i feel like it'd be different if my
original like degree was something more
like whoa i think that definitely helped
me a lot yeah
from like doctor to youtube it'd be like
no no no because i think that's too much
in the other direction then i think i
think doctor is like why would you throw
away the you put so much time into being
you definitely underestimate asian
parents though but i think but like they
wouldn't let you not be a doctor once
you are a doctor yeah yeah yeah but if
you had like computer science i'd be
like that's really good
could be i don't really understand it
though but i know what adoption is right
right
[Applause]
come on like you know
that's true if once you're a lawyer
there's no way your asian parents are
going to be like you can't not be a
lawyer
that's what i've been telling everyone
like lawyers
i think i think my the funniest thing
i've heard about like asian parents is
like considering how much they want
their child to become a doctor
that's exactly why they want their
children to be doctors so that they can
just go to their children
and they don't have to be like
they'll be like mate right give me a
mate
i am your father give me a maid right
well you see my my parents knew that i
was not
like
smart enough to have to expect too much
from me right so i think for youtube
they were like oh you get to like do
that thing you've been doing you love to
do since you were like four yeah yeah
yeah
[ __ ] okay sure good [ __ ] yeah go for it
so like how did they react to you to be
like i don't want to be a teacher
anymore how did they react to you when
you follow us
you have to have that talk yeah well
yeah because they were like when are you
going to take the exam like for your
credential program what are you going to
do and i was like i'm not going to i'm
doing youtube
i have 200 000 at this point i'd like
200. oh so you told them that you were
like quitting this path when you said
you were doing youtube so yeah okay so i
was like yeah
double whammy you're like i'm quitting
this i'm doing this now yeah and they
were like well because they didn't
really understand youtube that much so
they were just like what does that mean
why would they they're right yeah and
they're like are you making money and
i'm like yeah and they're like i mean if
you didn't know you could make money
when you first started making videos how
can you expect like elderly parents or
all their parents right yeah yeah so
what kind of content were you making
after the
drawing amv's or whatever then because i
assumed league of legends impressions
and then it went into the story time
right now because i was like oh this is
a funny why league of legends
impressions because she plays a lot of
league
we played a lot of things yeah we played
a lot of league and then it was in
college okay okay okay
i think that'd be fun i did it too
yeah we i i'm also in the same cringey
boat of like doing it yeah yeah i was
just i was just like why why are you
embarrassed about conor i thought i
thought like was like were you animating
connor's videos
that's why i was trying to like link
i i
saw what was your very first was your
very first
video about like um
story time about like conventions
or one of them no that was like
what was the first first story that you
talked about the first story was it like
or was it like anime protagonist [ __ ]
like 101 no i think it was like artist
pet peeves
right what was the one where you did
like the ax someone stole your artwork
or something that wasn't admired someone
else's like
2018
that was a little later down the line i
don't know when i when i got in touch
because i never saw you had twitter and
you didn't really use it at this point
yeah and you had like 1 000 followers
but i saw your video drawing and i was
like oh i like that video so i'll follow
her and then i think you followed me and
then i just messaged you being like hey
i want to draw can you help me i
remember the i think your recent video
at that time was like yuri on ice
impressions
god
you're like grabbing your ass
[Applause]
that's my favorite thumbnail that's
but then yeah i remember that uh we i
don't know why we spoke and then i think
well okay
i don't know what made us like talk
cause then i remember i was like oh i'm
thinking about doing this video where
i'd yeah league as well no i found out
you played league while we were doing
our first collab or something because i
was like i want to draw some stuff and i
wanted you to like roast me or something
but you were too nice
you weren't you weren't saying mean
things at all
oh how things are yeah
emily
and then yeah i think that's how we
became friends and then you asked me to
voice him on your videos i think and
then you know the ball came from from
there yeah then we played league